we're so tired last night I forgot to
close up the Vlog so let me just
say one good morning it's morning time
now and look at how cute this looks
yes
okay why is Tiger dirty what happened
yeah
let me see you show show everybody your
swollen but this is normal eyes see it's
nice and flat and CUNY look at this one
you see that little bump right there
hey
you see that see a little bump there it
is so it's usually from what I
understand I see them all the time as a
kid because we're so dirty like you play
on the playground and then just rub your
eye right away because the playground
has a ton of germs it clogged like a
pore or something so what my mom used to
do she would take one of her hairs pluck
it out and it should go in there and
then stick it in there and go like this
and like release it and they should put
some ointment on there but those are all
gravity I don't know if we need it
release it yeah look at that oh yeah
look at that yeah
oh my gosh so then should we just do
Urgent Care because I'm I don't have
a good door because that's like right
inside his eyelids
it's not even a big deal so then what do
we do we go to Urgent Care
does she assist yeah is it a stye
oh my God
[Music]
it makes me sad
IE boy he's still having lots of fun
[Music]
[Laughter]
my name
are you happy Papa's back home
[Music]
tell Papa what you said when um it was
your open house they remember we went
back to your school at night time yeah
top pop up tell Papa what you told me
what'd you tell me I said
um I one two three four and I was eating
dinner I was eating together and hot
dogs they're getting hot dogs
yeah he said he missed you so much he
said he wished you were there
um
so I'm doing some research
I don't feel that scared anymore but I
just hate the way it looks so I think he
has a star I'm a star is a painful red
bump on your eyelid Edge similar to
an acne pimple a style forms with a tiny
when a tiny oil gland near the eyelash
becomes blocked and gets infected so
that's a very common and in many cases
you can manage
uh stay at home you can manage a
stay-at-home period I mean maybe
you can manage to stay at home I don't
know that sentence was weird
however some cases may require treatment
by a doctor care provider
um
how common is this diet says a very
common and a curriculally in all Races
and genders how long will that last does
that usually last one to two weeks your
tummy's gonna look like this for one or
two weeks unless I go away by itself
um I still usually go away on its own
but in cases where it doesn't you may
need to rely on the eye care provider to
drain it
uh what causes a stye I think we already
covered that in the opening paragraph uh
what are some signs and symptoms of stye
size signs and symptoms of a stye
include a painful red bump along the
eyelid
uh near eyelashes swelling of your
eyelid sometimes the entire eyelid
crusting along the eyelid
light light
sensitivity soreness and itching is your
eye itchy monkey
oh
um
eye cheering a feeling that there's
something in your eye oh I remember
having a slide now that I heard that
part
it is itchy
can its thigh spreads thighs generally
aren't contagious good should I go to
work or send my child to school with
this thighs thighs aren't considered
contagious you can go to work or send
your child to school
when you have to start
so I think we're good
um how are studies treated a style will
usually go away on its own in one or two
weeks to feel better faster and reduce
pain and swelling you can use a
self-care plan to treat your stye at
home
so these are some do's and don'ts do use
a warm compress apply a warm washcloth
to the eyelid for 10 to 15 minutes at a
time from three to five times per day
we've warmed the washcloth by soaking it
in warm water ringing and repeat many
people believe that using green tea bags
Bart's right here
um
green tea bags moisten and warm water
careful because this camera might fall
as I compress this will help this is
stye not only feel better but also
spread speed healing doing part to the
antibacterial properties in green tea so
there is some sort of debate going back
and forth about this green tea that some
say some eye specialist doctors say it
does wear some say they don't but
generally this um it goes away by itself
in general what this article is say I'm
gonna hold it because I feel like Texan
drop it
um is if you try the green tea method it
doesn't hurt you so it doesn't hurt to
try
um Green Island don't squeeze or pop a
stye rub or touch your eyelid wear
makeup or contact lenses until you're
spicy okay monkey you can't wear makeup
okay you can't wear makeup until your
stye clears
what's the worm makeup
I mean some boys do
it's kind of cool
I've got Michael Karate Kid is a Boise
and he got her so he got makeup
okay how did we get there it's smart I
think you I've been in Karate Kid a boy
got like a bruise or something right and
they put makeup on me oh
I got kicked by Baldi
got it so yeah what's the plan of attack
Papa what's the plan of attack well
those underwear are very see-through
I don't know how to deal with this guy
goes away by itself
but it's gonna be itchy itchy no he's
just he's a boy that's it I trusted
that's the dad remedy because leave it
alone for three days if it's still there
we'll do something about it all right
dude
foreign
of course
don't touch any of them that's how you
guided in the first place
[Applause]
oh thank you
yeah oh that's a nice medley good job I
got it okay so we just finished training
at Sin City let's see if you can see
Sin City iron shout outs to our friend
said neverdeen who owns this
um right now what are we doing now oh we
told Tyco we were gonna get what are we
where are we going right now Tyga
we are not going to McDonald's
I told you we're not going to McDonald's
but we are going to get done look at
this little workout like he's doing clap
push-ups yeah those are really good
guess what you can get McDonald's no way
you're in pancakes
good job yeah so we're gonna go get
pancakes Papa what kind of diet are you
on today
let's see the hand it always uh
depends on the menu oh my god I've been
really good about JK news the last three
days yesterday
yesterday's Vlog because I had Krispy
Kremes I mean you had what I mean
another uh Rice Krispie treats oh okay I
didn't want to meet you I'm gonna throw
them away I want you to feel sad I
didn't even offer any to you
sad yeah yeah whatever okay so then
that's what we're doing next I want this
side of town so I'm sure there's a bunch
of cool places we haven't been to
someone look okay let's look let's see
where we end up
breakfast
is served
Papa copied me we got the same thing
mushroom and onions bacon eggs two extra
egg whites
I know
haha
so taika just woke up from a nap and
where are we dude's there and why do you
get a Build-A-Bear I have nine Spiderman
and what what is this with this nine
Spider-Man's Papa so let me pull this up
so if you guys remember we had another
Vlog where we came here
and taika was like I want to build a
bear and I was like well what did you do
to earn it he lost nothing about me in
addition to that you've been having a
little bit of trouble at school so we're
like you know you gotta earn it and then
he was like how do I earn it and we're
like well you got to get five Spiderman
that means he gets five stamps of doing
good good behavior
yeah yeah yeah nine oh my God so he
earned it and he surpassed the
expectation
show me how many show me nine two three
four five six seven eight nine yeah
I love how you still look like you just
woke up too yes
look at this look how many Spider-Man he
got that's just in two days this is in
two days so yeah two perfect days yeah
and then here he missed a Monday yeah
but that was Tuesday Wednesday was a
little rough but after that we made it
up but Monday out is here yep you
weren't here oh my God your eyes let's
go Duty I'll follow you I don't remember
where the store is maybe you can take me
nope I'll follow you
yeah
he's been thinking about this for day
weeks actually
oh there it is
okay
choose anyone you want you know his name
what's his name
oh did you know that I have no idea I
did not grow up with the Pokemon
Generation
we just missed it by like a year or two
okay you see all of these you could pick
any one you want and then you pick the
one like this that you want you want
this look do you want just a bear look
there's a regular bear you can get that
one
that's a big monkey one
like these are all just regular bears
yeah
okay okay wait wait one thing at a time
so we're gonna get a monkey
check you want to walk around yeah just
look at all of them there's a bunch of
them so I'll save this one keep it on
you but we'll see if there's any other
yeah are there any other ones you like
just one just one
this guy's pushing the boundaries man
hey hey he's a businessman you know
there's just negotiations on the table
do you see any over here on this side
you want to be any of these guys no no
no no no on this side oh These Guys
these guys these are the characters
these are the little stuffies Spiderman
one
you want you want a Spider-Man one or no
are you sure no think about it think
about it here give them that one in the
thinking pile you can have two yeah just
to think about any other ones what about
this bear look this guy looks soft
[Music]
Duty yes
okay what are we doing
all right it's okay
no no no keep thinking about it keep the
monkey keep sinking keep the monkey you
can keep thinking keep thinking
look at these again any of these guys
might be too many choices there's a
bunny
there's a wolf belongs
[Applause]
as long as I'm not that correct
[Applause]
so which one do you want this turtle
come here no
okay so which one did you pick the
monkey cheetahs I think the next station
is this I think but I'm not sure hold on
I think we need someone to help us
okay so monkey you're about to get this
stuff you're gonna come to life now
and what's your name how do you spell
that cheese
[Music]
good job
nice name say thank you
it was your foot under he's ready to
rock I think he saw somebody do it
okay
[Music]
what's about to happen
[Music]
look what's gonna happen to your little
monkey
[Applause]
s
it's coming to life you're putting in
all the insides
[Applause]
as you sleep with him
[Applause]
is it cool do you know what's going
inside of it yeah the fluffies good job
dude
thank you
[Applause]
oh he doesn't he wants to make sure that
it gets pressed
look at that guy he's so cute
[Applause]
oh my God I love him already monkey you
made a good choice
is that you like it you like the way it
feels okay she has to finish she has to
finish
[Music]
uh it's another heart but you're going
with that heart there you go all right
touch it let me see
me
oh he broke his heart
okay
all those yummy bananas
[Music]
a big big favor make a huge make a huge
wish you know a wish it's something you
want but keep it in your head what do
you want what's something you want I
want the monkey close up okay
I want The Monkey to close up that's a
good wish very practical I like it
because I I don't want to okay don't
leave don't leave you're not done hey go
back with the heart
[Music]
oh thank you all right
[Music]
you guys are ready I guess you can
always use the bathtub tonight right oh
to give him a bath
take a bath yeah
pay attention pay attention she's giving
you directions about your new friend and
whenever you're ready right behind our
experience where you can name your
foreign
okay don't leave your friend say thank
you
okay let's give him a bath
okay man monkey sorry you got the wrong
boy step on the thing step on the pedal
okay
look at all this bubble bath oh he's
gonna smell so good
done okay pick any outfit yeah
now we gotta look for what he wants to
wear
oh
okay dry him up
does it work
s
[Applause]
look at his hair
[Music]
okay what clothes is he gonna wear
outfits he has yep
[Applause]
Bucky come here look at all these
outfits
is he a boy is monkey cheeto a boy or a
girl
[Applause]
yeah but he needs clothes he's naked
right now let's give him clothes first
okay and then we'll get toys later
okay let's keep going we'll get the
shoes later let's just get clothes first
here
[Music]
there's wait keep looking more come here
let's look over here too there's a ton
on that side
Harry Potter
[Music]
okay let's keep looking here okay
dude what are the shorts
like those ones
oh is that why you want those okay put
it on him
you okay what's going on
quit tripping
any help you need help okay okay
that's cute he's starting to look like
daika he has a red shirt black shorts or
dark shorts is that what you like hold
them next to your monkey let's see
for the next year like like this hey
that's two monkey Cheetos okay what
shoes
which shoes do you want
you want rain boots
[Music]
there's black ones there's red ones
[Applause]
I am a doctor this already looks really
expensive is it really
you're such a genius
all right let's see this guy oh he looks
cutie
look at this guy look at his eyes
imagine this guy comes to life in the
middle of the night when he walks to
your bedroom he's cute
I
thought he's your friend
hey do you want one of these so you
carry him like that in a backpack
we gotta write his name so everyone
knows that that's his name is
what's his name Cooper okay so his name
is let me see furry friend's name
that's cutie okay
let's go pick up his little birth
certificate he was born today
his name's cooper cooper
[Applause]
ah there it is Cooper Quan oh is that we
put that wrong can we make this again
would that be possible I put the wrong
name here
okay I did I put the wrong name okay
we'll be right back
you gotta do it again
yep it's Cooper there we go kaika Quan
there's Cooper he was born today
looks just like this guy
bend over we are
okay monkey ring the bell so that
everyone knows that Cooper was born
today that Bell go ring it
that's it yay
look like
let's go dude no more no more no more
let's go let's go let's go thank you
no be nice thank you
so taika got to build his Bear yeah now
I'm gonna build your bear
we're going into Sephora
okay go for it
I'm just gonna go through the door
[Music]
okay so just got back home
um finished my Sephora run
um and I can't believe I didn't do this
sooner but I'm glad I did it this time
so there's a lot of the makeup the
reason why I went to Sephora obviously
to get makeup but
um since we're in the middle of a move I
didn't want to buy additional things and
just you know buy stuff because oh
that's so cute oh like imagination
scenarios where I feel like I'm gonna
need any makeup I didn't get any of that
stuff I just got the bare minimums
okay and a couple things okay
I have to okay but the thing that I did
that I'm like why didn't I do this
before duh instead of going based off a
memory I actually brought
my everyday makeup makeup bag
so
I'm a big huge fan
of drugstore makeup I feel like some
drugs for makeup is way better than
um like whatever Sephora or those types
of places carry just because it's a big
name brand doesn't really mean anything
to me it matters on the application uh
the formula sent all of this I take
everything into account
um
so
this is what I bought so I always wear
eyeliner for the most part I do wear
eyeliner
but I prefer wearing a brown and I ran
out of brown and everything's in storage
so you couldn't find any so I'm like all
right fine but I usually go with
um Rimmel I love the way it applies it
is on the thicker side in terms of the
little pencil
um but it's just so easy to work with I
don't really do liner that well I feel
like it just gives a very permanent too
sharp of a look and if I'm wearing it
every day I like it to look a little bit
fuzzy and just kind of like blend into
the natural oils with my face I feel
like it just looks more natural and
um like I said I use a brown so I've
been using black and it gives me more of
like a
dramatic look which is fun but I don't
like wearing it for an everyday
so I found hourglass they're voyeur oh
it Glides on so easy I do have to see
how it wears like throughout the day
like some of them do tend to fade away
or like
um I have normal skin but sometimes on a
hot day like this if you see like
my face is really oily because it's just
really [ __ ] hot
um if it's too oily or if I'm perspiring
too much it tends to rub off so I will
report back on hourglass but look
how beautiful
this is a brown I guess they call it
Chestnut which is a brown
um and then I saw this which is also
Brown and this is also from
hourglass and color Canyon but it's a
1.5 millimeter
behind me that is the Precision that I'm
going to get on this liner is going to
be like I'm wearing nothing at all
nothing at all from if you do we could
be best friends
now it's a mechanical gel eyeliner
I'll report back okay so I use a Milani
cream to powder foundation and it's not
really Foundation I don't use it as a
foundation I just used it for
my contouring
but it's been broken since forever it is
a cream like I said
that was in Sephora I brought it in with
me I applied it to my skin and then I
tried to match it as best as possible
with any brand honestly just because
I've only used structure Brown for this
um and I found the closest shade again I
don't know how it's gonna wear on a 12
to 24 hour day would it be 24 hours
maybe 16 hour
um and the closest I found in that shade
and in that consistency was fenty's
cream
what is this one called
freestyle cream bronzer
so this might even work better than this
one because this is just Foundation
whereas this is meant for contouring so
oh and I got it in shade
so report back on that
this right here is not a drugstore
makeup this is from benefit
um I do like a more natural look on my
eyelashes so I do like when the bristles
are more plastic than a brush and I
would use a drugstore brand too
it was by
L'Oreal I think
or Maybelline I can't recall but it's
called like
darn if I see the packaging I'll
remember but anyway they had ran out of
that
um I couldn't find it in the you know
the places where I would shop so then I
went to benefit to be like well okay if
you pay a little bit more then should it
be better and I I've tried so many
Brands I tried your I tried
um Gucci I tried
Lancome and none of them were as good as
my drugstore Maybelline slash L'Oreal
so then I was like all right
okay I just have to go back I can't find
the makeup I mean the
the the mascara that I like so I went to
benefit this is the closest but I'm
still not like
wowed over it
so the closest I've liked to it looking
natural like really long and just not
clumping and again natural was their
real magnet mascara in like black
I went with this but this is so old I
would legit have to put it underneath
running like warm running water pump it
a few times and then put it on and yeah
I need to trash this so I got the
replacement here
oh my God I just mixed both of them this
is a
is this the new one yeah this is a new
one
there it is
there's a bristle again
that I really do like
okay
but then because I'm not the biggest fan
of it I'm not committed to it nor am I
married to it so I had to try one size
which already feels or looks at least in
terms of the bristle and just the
formula like it might be close to my
drugstore one so I gotta try it out
and report back but so far just based on
looks I like it
oh another thing about this one that I
liked is
um you know when you put it on and you
layered it on it starts creating like
these little balls and then the balls
start like kind of falling on your
cheeks it doesn't do that so but it also
doesn't make them as long as it would
like so
there's that
um and then I use this is like my daily
Sonia kashuk
little
lip tint and it looks really natural
oh that's what I forgot to find but it's
like this fat thick pencil
that I don't have a sharpener for us
supposed to buy the sharpener because
I've like legit used it to where it's
literally scratching
my lips so I'm like oh let me just find
a replacement instead of finding the
[ __ ]
sharpener anyway so the clothes I found
to that was
what's this brand Charlotte it is
something very yeah in Pillow Talk what
a beautiful shade
got that
um oh my concealer I love using born
this way it looks really natural Glides
on stays on forever super coverage
um I wear a natural beige
but they ran out of it like are there
too many of us wearing it or they just
don't order enough I don't know so I
just kind of went with the in between so
I like wearing a summer shade because I
tend to get darker this summer and then
a lighter shade
um in the winter time obviously so I got
the the in-betweens of my natural one
because they didn't have it so I went
with
golden beige and then I got a warm beige
so the warm beige obviously for
summertime so I think I could still wear
it now and then a golden beige
um is what I'll wear in because it's
really close to natural beige so I'll
probably wear this
and replacing that
um and yeah
did I not get a oh
I thought I got
a cream I guess I didn't so I thought I
got a cream blush because legit I have
been using my YSL lipstick as my blush
in this shade it is so cute and it's
creamy and it's thick
um and it gives it this dewy effect but
I guess I didn't find anything to
replace this so for the meantime I will
be wearing lipstick on my cheeks and the
nose of my bridge
that was it
I think I got everything covered
that was just way so fun okay and these
are things I didn't need that I still
bought but I still kind of sort of need
so I got Moroccan oil
for these golden locks and then
this for my face soothing glowing
complexion I really don't know what it
is but I see it everywhere and I'm like
okay
the Magazine's pretty you got me and
these are the things that they put at
the checkout line which is my favorite
part of Sephora and they know what
they're doing they know that we're going
to be stuck there for a minute and I
think the cash registered
clerks or whatever they I think they
train them to go really slow so all of
us can stand there and look at all these
little mini size things and they're so
cute because they're mini size and
there's never been a time where I've
been able to walk through that island
and not buy something
that's like a Target
in aisle fashion for makeup
they get me every time and this is what
I got
okay
[Applause]